you're one of those guys out there that
that is able to point to facts and doing
it do it in a comedic way
where you kind of walk this fine line
where you don't get banned from
you know platforms because it's kind of
deemed as comedy um
you've been doing this for a while right
like how long did how long ago did you
create this character of robert frank
615 sitting in his car yelling and
spitting all like jack tan juicy as hell
right
well the um i i started making videos
uh at the tail end of 2012 early 2013
um when vine was kind of phasing out and
instagram videos just started
but the the actual rage character that i
did
yeah i'm just gonna put it up but i'm
not gonna play the audio just so we
don't get any issues there's a lot of
swearing in it but
yeah no no worries no worries the um
that guy
started for maybe three or four videos
on my youtube channel in like 2015 i
started doing it but
they were getting no traction at all
like i would get a couple
hundred views couple thousand views here
and there um
and then the one video pokemon go when
that was the big
craze and phase and everybody was doing
that um
that video was july of 2016 i believe
and that's when things just that videos
got like a billion views on social media
by now
and i was like oh hey maybe we have
something here so i started doing it
more and more and
i evolved the character from just
screaming
to then i became like a rapper and you
know i'm making my words rhyme but still
being motivating and inspiring and
i really didn't expect the character to
be loved or
to to be something that people wanted to
see
i wanted to be hated i wanted people to
look at me and say who the hell is this
greased up guy yelling at me with a
bandana how old is he like i wanted to
be hated and
it turned out that people loved the
character did you still get hate from
people for any reasons
oh of course yeah i mean i still get
hate now especially with what happened
to me they're like
what happened to you couldn't have
happened to a better guy i hope you die
you know we get those all the time but
when you put yourself out there and i'm
sure you get it too
because you're very you know you you
walk the controversial line and
even though you're telling the truth and
everything you say i'm sure you get
your share of haters as well oh yeah
yeah yeah you know i call those my
biggest fans you know they watch
everything i do but they hate on me it's
like you're a fan
oh of course yeah yeah um so
okay so you created this stuff starting
from vine um
i didn't come across you until i was
just like sit kicking back watching a
joe rogan episode he actually mentioned
you in the episode
i think he put it up on the tv jamie
threw it up on the screen behind him i'm
like yeah oh this guy seems interesting
so i started to follow you on instagram
um and it's been hilarious to like watch
you take current events and just kind of
like chop them up and like break them
down for what they are
um so we won't spend too much time on
that
you guys should go follow robert on his
social um
where's the best place for people to get
those older videos is it mostly on
instagram is where they're all posted
um yeah i mean they're on my actually to
be honest they're on every platform
um i i post everything everywhere for
the most part and robert frank 615 is
the name everywhere so you could easily
find me
how did you come up with robert frank
615 was that like a gamer handle or
something when you're a kid no
no no i i'm 43 years old man i stopped
playing video games when i was like 12.
but
um the name the name just came from that
was what i picked when i first
started an instagram account and
everything and if i knew where it was
going to go i would have picked a much
cooler name but
robert frank 615 kind of stuck and now
people
know me by that cool cool and rob robert
is my first name frank is my middle name
and 615 is my birthday june 15th so
that's where
all that comes in got it got it
you